uh and we know that this kind of a
pullback is reckless
it's dangerous it puts american security
at risk
it will provide an opportunity for
terrorists to be able to establish safe
havens again
it also puts the women of afghanistan at
risk it puts the women of afghanistan
into the position that they were in
potentially 20 years ago
where their lives are not valued where
they have no freedom
the united states of america went to
afghanistan because our security
depended upon it because we were
attacked by al qaeda
because the taliban hosted al qaeda that
relationship
continues so a withdrawal of forces that
isn't based on conditions on the ground
is fundamentally dangerous the
president's apparently going to say we
went to afghanistan because of a
horrific attack that happened 20 years
ago
but that cannot explain why we should
remain there in 2021
and i would say that does explain
exactly why we must remain there we know
what happens if terrorists establish
safe havens we must ensure it doesn't
happen again
and finally i would say the president is
obligated by law
that we passed in the ndaa last year
to certify the conditions have been met
for the enduring defeat
of al qaeda and isis before he initiates
any significant withdrawal
and that is an obligation we expect that
the white house
will uphold and will meet again it's an
obligation that they
they have by law we passed in the ndaa
last year
and so with that i'm going to yield to
the republican leader of the homeland
security committee mr catco
thank you very much uh thank you all for
uh being here today
uh i just got back my second trip to the
border uh
steve has been there as well and others
and um i just want to kind of give you
some things you might not be getting
from others with with respect to what's
going on at the border
um we've received briefings from customs
and border protection in texas
the texas rangers texas highway patrol
ice homeland security investigations
here's some things that they told us uh
in the rio grande valley section alone
they personally observed at least 15 000
people come across the border who got
away
we don't know whether they're terrorists
we don't know whether they're drug
traffickers
we don't know whether they're criminals
we don't know anything about them
because they got away
uh over capacity of the donna processing
facilities at 420 percent right now
and you see from the pictures it's hard
to even tell that they're humans i'm
sent my wife one of those pictures the
other day
and she didn't realize that those were
all humans because they're all wrapped
up so tightly
and piled on top of each other's
children exactly girls are arriving
pregnant
uh as young as 11 years old we saw one
woman who
reportedly was repeatedly raped at nine
years old by drug traffickers along the
way
there's at least a ten percent positive
testing rate for individuals tested
uh for covet here none of them are being
tested at this facility
they don't want to be tested because if
they test positive they have to
quarantine them and there's no place to
put them
they're being released into our
communities uh without with at least 10
of them on average being
testing positive for um coven
something you may not realize is
happening we saw this firsthand
we were there at midnight two people who
stopped midnight
were on the planes for us with us the
next day going to a destination
we are being told through debriefings
that the individuals are saying to have
family in san francisco for example or
philadelphia for example
but oftentimes those are where they have
the drug traffickers are telling they
have to go
to work off the fee it takes them across
the border and so
um think about this they are there the
night before
the next morning they're released and
not tested most likely
they are released and given a plane
ticket oftentimes by the ngos the ngos
are getting money from fema
so we're ultimately paying for those
plane tickets to put them somewhere
where they said they're going
when they come to us they don't have any
id
they say their name could be joe smith
we have no way to know whether it's joe
smith
or whether there's someone on the terror
watch list we have no idea they go they
then get allowed to
go onto an airplane with no id
think about that how many of us can go
on an airplane without an id
they are doing that they are given this
packet on the front of the packet is
that
and on the back of the packet is that
what you see over there
right please help me i do not speak
english the paperwork inside is in
english telling them what they're
supposed to appear what they're supposed
to do next
and they don't speak english so what are
we doing why are we paying for this why
are we putting people
on planes not knowing whether or not
they test the possible covert
in a close environment like that the
donna processing facility for example
19.2 million dollars a month to operate
that's not including
uh the daycare center which is overrun
it's not including the medical
facilities which are 54 million dollars
a year
at that facility alone uh they are so
overwhelmed that they're forced to
release thousands and thousands of
illegal family units
into the interior without even giving
them a court date without me giving a
date to appear for anything they're just
being
released in because there's nothing else
they can do um i could go on and on but
i i want to leave you with this because
i think it's important
these are quotes from the law
enforcement we had on the border
the biggest thing you can do for us is
allow us to enforce laws that are
already on the books
the federal government is becoming the
biggest facilitator of human smuggling
across the border
by not delivering consequences when
people break the law and send people to
their final destinations after they
cross the border
illegally that's them saying it that's
the front lines that's border patrol
saying that
no one crosses a border from mexico
without the cartels being involved in
getting paid
the seasonal trend talking point is a
complete myth
in areas where we have implemented
border wall systems we have shifted 80
percent of illegal activity
in that area to areas where we are
better able to interject
we need to person we need personnel
technology and infrastructure
and lastly i'll tell you this the
cartels which
are net deep involved in this and are
being enriched more than anything else
they
do about 15 million dollars a day are
advertising on facebook
for smuggling these people across and
they're advertising on tick tocks
sending out videos of their smuggling
and advertising on craigslist just to
hire drivers to smuggle people across
and they're advertising and trying to
recruit uber drivers
this is a crisis reinforced by the
executive orders on january 20th
and it's universal to them all the
people on the front lines that if we
went back to where it was before those
executive orders
we would effectively stop this problem
and uh i don't know who's up next
all right i'll yield back thank you
thanks mike mccall and ranking member on
the foreign affairs committee
for me this is a personal uh i live in
texas
i was a federal prosecutor in texas i
dealt with this issue when i was a
federal prosecutor
i chaired the homeland security
committee for three terms
uh in congress this is a crisis
make no mistake and in the many years
i've been covering this issue
i've never seen it this bad i just got
back with
whip squeeze nan to the rio grande
valley
sector the busiest sector in the united
states
uh we went to a nighttime tour of the
border
thousands of people coming in children i
call it a trail
of tears because it was so sad
to see a five-year-old girl in tears not
knowing where she is
without her parents without her family
and we talked to some of them in spanish
took him 40 days
to cross from guatemala up to
the border 40 days of misery
all created by the president united
states by the stroke of a pen
2014 was nothing compared to this nor
was 2019.
they'll tell you it's seasonal the
border patrol sector chief
rio grande valley who i trust and not
the politicians tells me
it's not seasonal there's a direct cause
and effect between the president's
actions
first day in office a stroke of a pen
wiping out
the remaining mexico policy that was
working
remain in mexico in the asylum
cooperation agreements
with central america this is not only
a humanitarian crisis not only threat to
our national security
not only a homeland security issue but
it's a foreign policy
blunder i talked to secretary pompeo he
negotiated the remaining mexico
agreement that was working it required
them to stay in mexico
while awaiting their asylum claims or
safe third country
like guatemala so what's happening now
because of the recision
the traffickers are smart and they know
that
america is open for business now and
guess what they're coming
and for each one of these children that
we saw in that facility
as horrific as that looks we expect to
see this in foreign countries
we don't expect this in the united
states of america
for god's sakes but this is real
and it's because of the president's
actions on the first day in office
this needs to stop he can do with the
stroke of a pen to reverse this course
and what really is heartbreaking to me
is to see those border patrol agents
that i've worked with for
so many years of my career so
demoralized
40 percent of their time is going down
to babysit not on the front lines 40
percent now have to
drive buses and babysit and be
caregivers
rather than the job they were hired to
do
they were signing up for early
retirement and it's just wrong
and kamala harris if she's in charge i
don't know she is
she needs to come down the president
needs to as well
but this has to stop and it it can stop
i've been discussing this
issue with the ambassadors of the
northern triangle
i will be meeting with them later this
evening and
the the ambassador from mexico to look
for solutions
there is a solution that can stop this
but with no action at all out of the
white house
it's going to continue and it's going to
get worse going into the springtime
we know the numbers are going to drive
traffickers make 15 million dollars a
day
half a billion dollars a month
exploiting these children and extorting
the families in central america so um
i've never thought i would see it this
bad in my career
but it is this bad and it needs to stop
and the president can stop it
with a stroke of a pen just like he
started the whole thing
with the stroke of the pen with that uh
i wanted to introduce ann wagner on the
the vice ranking member on the foreign
affairs committee thank you very very
much anne wagner i represent st
louis the suburbs of st louis missouri
this very second congressional district
i i appreciate the whip for taking
a group of us down to the border uh yet
again i've been before
and i can tell you what we saw was both
horrifying
and heartbreaking to be perfectly honest
uh 172 000
that actually turned themselves in or
were picked up in the month of march
alone
that doesn't talk about the the tens of
thousands that are actually escaping
undetected across our nation's
border and that number is growing and
you know what the trek and the triple
only get more dangerous as as the months
get hotter
and hotter and hotter these open
border policies that were completely
created
by this president joe biden must
be turned around there are three things
that he can do
reinstate the trump policy that worked
which was remain
in mexico the second has to do with the
asylum cooperation agreement
with the three northern triangle
countries which is you know what
you can apply for asylum but do it in
central america
don't make the track here
and the third frankly is title 42 which
is a public health exclusionary order
that says
during covid um and during a pandemic we
should not be allowing anybody
to come in not only is it the covet
that's coming
in um there were there were there were
holding
bins i don't know what else to call them
like this
filled with children that had signs on
them that said
suggest suspected chickenpox
and other uh diseases that are are
coming
across and what this is happening is
doing is it's being moved into the
interior my own home state of missouri
and beyond uh you've got crime
that's coming in undetected you have
coveted and other diseases coming in
and you also have the cost of the
american people because you know what
i was on a plane also from mcallen texas
and
uh half the plane was filled with the
oversized manila envelope families
that were being moved in buses uh
cars vans they're all being moved into
the
interior they'll be on our social
welfare programs maybe
sadly for life a drain on the healthcare
a drain on um
on our education system so this is a
crisis
that was created by president joe biden
president trump had the policies in
order
they need to go back to those he broke
this
and he needs to own it and he needs to
fix it
he also needs to go down to the border
along with
vice president harris and they need to
talk to these border patrol agents
as we heard 40 percent of them these
field agents are off the job
fighting crime in cartels and they are
literally processing children
and serving as caregivers this is
something that
we can no longer hide about i had three
20-year veteran
border patrol agents say they feel
abandoned
and said go back and be a truth teller
for us and that's what we're here to do
today thank you
thank you ann for for telling the truth
and this is
going to be something we're going to
continue to do we're going to continue
to raise awareness
uh to this crisis at america's southern
border it was exclusively created by
president biden
when he with the stroke of a pen right
when he took the oath of office
undid policies that were working to
control our southern border
it had a ripple effect that immediately
resulted
in people coming by the thousands a day
illegally across the rio grande and
other parts
of our southern border with the members
that have gone down the border they've
all seen the same things
we went with border patrol agents we
went to a shift change and then they
took us out to one of the temporary
processing centers
right by the rio grande river and it was
it was alarming
as ann said it was heartbreaking to see
what was going on within minutes
we saw just parades of people coming
across and they were coming across in
groups of maybe five or six
because that's how many would fit on the
rafts that were being
deployed from the mexico side right
across the rio grande they'd send them
over
a group of five or six would come
through the the brush
and then they would go and start getting
processed and then a few
minutes later another group and another
group and it was constant
the entire night around midnight we went
over by the rio grande as we were
going that way we saw more people just
coming through
under brush young children many of them
unaccompanied
the abused sexual abuse and rape that is
happening to these
young girls uh is is heartbreaking it
should be
something that president biden
acknowledges and stops
he can stop this today he won't go down
to the border
we're calling on president biden to go
down to the border
himself and see what he created this
mess
that he's created uh and the carnage
these kids are going through right now
this is a detention facility right here
it's a cell it's a holding cell
that's set up by the federal government
this one was designed for 33 people
there were over 400 kids in that cell
the day we went there and there were
multiple cells like this set up
every one of them with over 400 people
that were designed for 33
kids they're on top of each other a
large percentage
have coveted which means it's got to be
spreading through everybody
but in the meantime imagine a restaurant
back home in any state in america
if you're over a hundred percent
capacity with state guidelines
they're going to probably shut that
restaurant down here you've got the
federal government running a facility
with
holding cells over a thousand percent
above capacity where the government
would shut somebody down if they were
doing this in the private industry
the federal government is doing this to
these young kids uh
it's the definition if you read texas's
law on
child abuse and neglect what's happening
in that federal facility
in the the biden administration is
running violates
uh texas's own laws it's it's it's a
national disgrace
and president biden puts kamala harris
in charge of it and she refuses to go
down
maybe she because she doesn't want to be
associated with this disgraceful policy
but if she's the vice president united
states and the president put her in
charge of this
vice president harris needs to go down
to the border and see this for herself
because maybe she would then encourage
president biden to reverse his policies
that have
failed again you can go back to the
trump policies remain in mexico
everybody will tell you that policy was
working the border patrol agents tell us
it's not like you get 10 opinions when
you ask the same question to 10
different people
our border patrol agents are all telling
us the same thing one
they signed up for this tough job
because they want to stop the drug
cartels from bringing drugs into america
what's happening now is the drug cartels
are running america's southern border
they're making millions of dollars a day
off of this enterprise
that was created by president biden's
executive actions
and they don't want to be at midnight
changing diapers when instead they could
be stopping
fentanyl and heroin from coming into
america's uh border but that's what
they're doing right now because that's
what president biden's policy
has created president biden created it
he can reverse it today
he needs to go see for himself the
damage that he's doing and stop this
madness
uh one final point i'll make before we
open up to questions
starting shortly we are going to be
uh initiating a discharge petition on
ann wagner's born a live act
so cat connect from florida will be
filing the discharge petition if 218
members of congress sign that discharge
petition it will bring the bill to the
floor immediately
that says if a baby is born alive
outside the womb it can't be murdered
and called abortion unfortunately that's
happening in states like new york and
others
that are looking to to continue this
barbaric practice
the only way to stop it is with an act
of congress speaker pelosi won't bring
the bill to the floor but with 218
signatures
that bill can come to the floor on its
own so we are going to be found that
discharge petition this morning
uh hopefully we'll get enough signatures
five democrats
signing on will bring that bill to the
floor and i know a lot more
democrats than that ran saying they were
pro-life you can't be pro-life if you
don't sign this discharge petition
so that's going to start today and of
course at noon today we're going to be
very proud
to be at the swearing-in of julia letlow
which
she will be our newest member of
congress but as the dean of the
louisiana delegation
i'm especially proud of julia getting
sworn in uh we were so saddened
uh to see the death of her husband luke
just days before his swearing in
julia just got elected special election
she will become
the first republican woman ever elected
to congress from louisiana
we're incredibly proud to have her
joining our conference
and louisiana's congressional delegation
in a few hours but that be happy to open
up the questions um
a few days ago uh former president trump
got some tough words for senator
mcconnell i'm not gonna repeat what he
said but i'm curious uh your thoughts on
this
thought does the former president not
the republican leaders
of taking control of congress we're very
focused on taking back the house
next year and frankly when you look at
the socialist agenda being pushed by
speaker pelosi and president biden
people are turning away from it they're
talking about an infrastructure bill
it's soviet-style infrastructure what
they're talking about
over 90 percent of the bill they're
proposing
has nothing to do with roads and bridges
uh people would expect if you're going
gonna have a trillions of dollar two
trillion dollar bill
that it would be all about roads and
bridges there's is not it's a lot of
green new deal
it's uh you know expanding the role of
the federal government it's raising
taxes on hard-working families
national association of manufacturers
said that hard-working families would
lose over a million jobs in america
if they got this bill passed so
president obama should be working with
republicans on a bipartisan agreement he
still refuses to even meet
with republican leadership so when you
look at all of this far left socialist
policy they're pushing
it's no surprise that a lot of democrats
are getting nervous they know
that our opportunity to win the house
back has never been greater next year
and we're focused on doing that you saw
the record-breaking numbers uh that
we've raised over this
first quarter record-breaking uh and uh
i think it shows you that people are
focused on
getting the house back putting a check
and balance on this radical out of
control about an administration
oh i'm sure president trump will play an
active role and you know he said it's
it's very uh you know very
he's very interested in hoping to win
the house back and i think a lot of
americans across the country
who may have voted for president biden
and some of speaker pelosi's
uh democrat members of congress are
alarmed by
just how far left uh towards the
socialist agenda they moved in a short
time
um
do you have confidence in them well you
know we've heard a lot of stories i mean
obviously i've met
read their media reports but there's
been nothing that we've seen yet from
the department of justice
if something's going on obviously we'll
find out about it uh you know right now
it's it's hard to speculate on on rumors
but you know if something really formal
happened from justice we would of course
react and take action oh well look i
haven't talked to him to
get his uh you know get his explanation
of what's been alleged
serious things alleged obviously we want
to get the facts
will be this week i haven't seen him uh
we just had a conference meeting
uh you know we're we're still hybrid
where we have in person and people
virtually he wasn't
he wasn't there in the room i'm not sure
if he was on uh
uh you know there have been a few cases
where members have had
charges filed against them for various
things and we've removed them
from committees uh immediately when that
happened that's been
the precedent uh that we've always
followed
can you get your reaction to the job
well you know the first two vaccines
that were approved are still
uh very effective and safe uh this one
we'll see if it may actually be
reinstated
let the fda run their process we have dr
fauci
uh and dr wilinski the cdc director
coming before the select
subcommittee on coronavirus which i'm
the ranking republican
on uh majority whip clivert is the
chairman of that committee
uh they will be coming before our
committee thursday tomorrow
and i'm sure this will be one of the
many things that we'll be discussing
well you know you you want to encourage
people to to get a vaccine if they want
to and
if you look at the johnson and johnson
decision
it was based on not not a specific
finding but they said they saw some
people that had blood clots that had
gotten that they want to see if it's
related to the vaccine this is the fda
process
and the fcfda is still the gold standard
in the world
for approval of vaccinations we
were able to get a vaccination out for
multiple vaccinations out for covet
in record time but they didn't cut any
corners if you look at moderna pfizer
they were heavily tested on tens of
thousands of americans
and and it seems to be yielding very
positive results
with johnson and johnson let's see what
the fda processes there i
i have confidence in the fda's process i
think we're still the gold standard in
the world
and in other countries look to us still
for guidance
on how to properly approve and
distribute vaccines
well thank you all we'll see all on the
floor for julius warhead
oh